- Today we're gonna talk
about how law school
is just like the LSAT.
And also how it is completely different.
(mellow music)
Lilian reached out to me and said,
hello, I came across your
page and I'm so glad I did.
I'm currently preparing to
take the LSAT in September.
I will hopefully attend
law school next fall.
I was wondering if you had
any tips on LSAT preparation.
When I wrote my response to Lilian,
it actually got me thinking
about how preparing for the LSAT
was actually kind of similar to the way
that I prepared for my law school finals.
So here is a condensed version
of my response to Lilian.
First tip number one, take
a well-known prep course.
It's, of course, a lot of
money, but it's money well spent
because the LSAT is a
test unlike any other test
you'll ever take.
It involves reading
comprehension, logic games,
and it's very unusual.
But what you find is that
as you become more familiar
with the LSAT, you learn
the strategies that help,
you learn how to take logic games,
you learn how to comprehend
the reading sections
that are provided.
It just takes time and it
takes a lot of practice.
Believe it or not, law school
is actually very similar.
Law school exams are unlike
anything in undergrad.
A law school essay is nothing like
a college exam or college essay.
But the more you familiarize yourself
with law school essays, the
better you can become at them.
Just like there are
strategies for the LSAT,
there are strategies that you can learn
to take an issue-spotting
exam and ace it every time.
It just takes time and it takes practice.
And that brings me to the
second point I told Lilian.
Take lots of practice exams.
Before I took the LSAT,
I took every single
publicly available LSAT
that I could get my hands on.
The summer before my
LSAT, I studied every day,
probably from nine to five on weekdays
and probably from nine to six on weekends.
I considered it my job to take
as many practice tests as possible.
Because as I said before, I could see
that taking the LSAT was a skill.
And like any skill, you get better at it
the more you practiced.
And it's the same with law school.
Get your hands on as many
practice exams as you can.
It's okay if you're taking
exams from professors
that are not at your school.
It's okay if they're 10 years old.
In law school, the law that's
taught in your first year
doesn't really change that much.
And as a result, you can
take tests from 20 years ago.
You can take tests from other
schools and other professors.
Get your hands on as many as you can
and take as many practice tests as you can
as early as you can.
If you do that, you will get
better at law school exams,
and you are much more likely to get A's
when it comes to the
actual test in your class.
And that brought me to the
third thing I told Lilian.
Take practice exams under
non-ideal circumstances.
On test day you're going to be stressed,
you're going to be tired,
you're going to be distracted.
When Lilian takes the LSAT,
it's not gonna be on her schedule,
it's going to be on their schedule.
It's far too easy to take
practice exams on your schedule,
after you've had coffee,
after you've had a good night's sleep,
when there's no pressure.
Once you've established
a baseline competence,
take practice tests with the music on,
with other distractions,
immediately upon waking up,
or at three o'clock in the morning.
And always take practice exams
under real time pressure,
because I guarantee when you walk in
to your first law school final exam,
you're going to be freaked out.
It's a natural reaction.
But if you can practice under
non-ideal circumstances,
then you're going to be way ahead
of all of those other people
who are taking the same exam
and are even more
freaked out than you are.
When I responded to
Lilian, I realized that
taking the LSAT and taking
a law school final exam
and the way that you prepare for them
are actually pretty similar.
Unfortunately, there is
little to no carry over
between the strategies
that go into the LSAT
and the strategies that go
into a law school final exam.
Issue spotting exams
are just two different.
But the underlying
methodology is the same.
So when you get to law school,
don't throw the baby
out with the bath water.
Use your good habits that you learned
when you practiced the LSAT
and bring that into law school,
and you'll be way ahead of everybody else.
Oh, and one last thing.
If you're getting ready for
law school, check this out.
We've put together a free e-book called
The Ultimate Pre-Law Checklist.
Just click the link below to download.
It's some of our best tips and strategies
for getting ahead before
you start law school,
and it will put miles
ahead of your classmates.
Just click below.
And also, if you like this video,
please subscribe to our channel.
We come out with new videos
on how to crush law school all the time.
So thanks a lot, and
thanks for stopping by.
(upbeat music)